and as coalition talks progress here in
germany there's one thing the three
parties hoping to govern together do
agree on legalizing cannabis and the
social democrats greens and liberals
want a regulated system for the
cultivation distribution and sale of
cannabis it's not just consumers who
could benefit but also the
pharmaceutical industry
germany would follow luxembourg as the
second eu member state to legalize
cannabis
and with me in the studio now is dw
reporter pablo foley elias pablo welcome
as always uh why are these three parties
that look likely to govern in germany so
determined to legalize cannabis right
well the greens and the liberal fdp um
have long been in favor of legalizing it
the spd so the socialists are
also on board now but they're taking
let's say a little bit more of a
cautious approach to things but they do
realize that it is a social reality and
for that reason a political approach is
absolutely necessary there are multiple
reasons why they've always uh the greens
and the ftp have been in favor of it and
most of the cannabis sold here in
germany as is the case in in many
countries where it's not legal and it's
on the black market of course and that
means that there's no quality control
and also the profits go to normally
organized crime so a good way of you
know by legalizing is that you kind of
remedy that issue and also it ensures
the safety of cannabis as you know if
it's regulated properly and then there
are age restrictions and so on and so
forth now there are countries where it
has been legalized and in fact germany
would not be the first eu state uh to do
it how would it be regulated if it were
legalized here well at the moment it's
unclear how they would go about it
they've got a couple of models that they
could that they could look at
the most obvious that we've you've just
mentioned is luxembourg berg of course
neighboring country and but some of the
ideas that have already been floated um
by the greens and the ftp for example is
that they would like to see cannabis
sold in specialty shops for anybody
who's been to the united states and
they're these so-called dispensaries
it's almost like a liquor store where
you go and you buy your cannabis the
liberal ftp have also floated the idea
of perhaps having the pharmacy network
selling those but there are people who
are against it because they say that you
know this is potentially a recreational
drug um and that would mean that it
doesn't really make sense that you go to
get a recreational drug at a pharmacy um
also with regards to regulation would be
similar in some ways to alcohol in that
there would be a minimum age and if we
look at the case of luxembourg if we
were to if germany were to follow that
the sale and distribution would be
regulated very much so by the state and
so with regards to supply chain and the
market you've mentioned a few of them
but what are some of the other benefits
to legalization that they are putting
forth in making this argument that it is
time to legalize cannabis well you
mentioned that there one of the big
benefits would be of course for business
the pharmaceutical industry would be
very interested in having it and it's
also there's been this long-held belief
that you know cannabis leads to harder
drug consumption but of course that's
now being uh sort of sidelined let's say
a little bit but it's very much related
to the pharmaceutical industry and
business where uh there's a lot of
support for regulation right a lot of
money to be made on the taxes there okay
exactly claire pablo foley elias thank
you as ever for coming in the studio
with that update